[Music]
no pay no play news no what no plan
submitted by the sound guy who a GPS
company removes a suspected killers
ankle monitor after he failed to pay the
monthly fee I hate it when that happens
he had to pay the monthly fee as part of
his bond so Clint Walker hmm
and accused the accused killer was out
on $100,000 bond but as part of the bond
he has to have a monitor on him which is
given by a third party GPS company in
the contract he has to pay those fees if
he's released on bond himself as part of
the deal I guess if the bond is cleared
so he didn't pay it
so GPS company went to him and took off
the monitor that's like hey you're not
paying we're not here you know yeah I
always assumed it was the police that we
had that as your bill cuz it's like the
courts aren't happy with letting it go
the courts are saying the GPS company
violated the terms and their
understanding of their deal
there was a call we'd be like yo he's
not paying his bill let us know first
yeah something they just went and just
took him off Jesus that's so like why is
he the one that's paying for it like I
don't know when I go back to olden time
and they're like yo you see this rope
you need to take that rope you need by
that rope before we hang cross up the
hill guillotine man you need to build
the oh that's kind of people do like
those criminals we're like all right
like do your grave or whatever get it
yeah you got it and then what you're
talking about
hi cool job done for me this guy is a
mastermind at the system do you think he
did it on purpose
see that's not saying
that the third-party company had you
know release him of that anklet because
he didn't pay he actually read the terms
and if you're if you're home all day
under house arrest and you got an ankle
bracelet can't do anything might as well
read the terms in that's all I'd be
playing call of duty with mobile DEA of
the county is saying this is a loophole
and if he can do it you know who knows
who else out there whose Alfre bond he's
she's saying literally people are
walking free while bond there are
potential murderers you know so yeah
that's her concern it's like this is not
this is like gonna be a loophole and
it's statistics show that there's at any
time about 173 cases where there's
individuals out on bond on a murder case
or murder charge they're playing the
system they know how to work yeah so
I've definitely something that I think
criminals are catching on to so well now
they are with this article Jesus know
now we're just blowing it up easy
bracelet just don't pay hey if you're if
you're locked up in jail don't pay what
you're supposed to pay and then your
walk out Scotch other easy don't hate
exactly you know it's crazy see if that
guy does it again caught it and he like
I ain't do it like he didn't do it like
whatever you was like being accused of
before you know he got on his bottom
every delay eat he was still like
claiming this this after that [ __ ] after
you run like that but if you park raised
like that they'll try that [ __ ] they
play the system it's like what yeah any
like yeah yeah yeah it take me take me
to trial is like obviously can't we just
be like that dude did it go away that's
why I never liked about like judicial
system yeah there's some parts of that
only such a long time to even get to
court right again it we got to find a
juror the one to like you know can stand
this murder case or whatever but it
takes literally months same with death
row to like if it's one of those people
who confess to killing 19 hundred people
or something like that and then you have
DNA evidence i watch it and they're so
like yeah was that a late like 15 years
yeah like dude wait no plugin kill him
on the spot right now it was crazy this
dude like you potentially kill somebody
but he's his bond was a hundred grand
you know that's like in a bigger picture
at a bigger scheme of things that's very
small to a huge come
yeah how is he out on a hundred grand
pond because he had to wear a monitor so
works more on the black market
oh yeah I like you too obvious even you
think that's how you should do research
it like but then like would you rather
have it take a long time innocent until
proven guilty or immediately everybody
judges you as guilty I mean it always
depends on what but yeah for situations
like that [ __ ] it's like you obviously
did it bro
yeah like that's the scary part and you
know what you thinking oh no I'm just
saying like you're talking extremes at
that point or not not talking extremes
but like certain circumstances where
what if they're actually like innocent
yeah and all the fingers are being
pointed all they're all like Harrison
Ford and the fugitive exactly I don't
care is it wouldn't you not mind having
ankle monitor but that's what are you
kidding me still paying a hundred
thousand dollar bond
[ __ ] yeah but but I still don't see why
he was the one who had to pay for it
like yeah families as part as a bond as
part of like they just worked like
they've been working with his company
for 20 years account apparently and
they've never experienced anything like
this but they never that they know of
exactly but immediately terminated their
the contractor their contract with them
but you know yeah you we don't know like
how many of these things happened maybe
they were just caught you know so that's
like a they're the ones who have all
that in for the company is the one who
has all the information yeah and it
doesn't even say why they need to use a
GPS third party I feel like I think all
of us would would in mind our tax
dollars going to some ankle monitor
that's on go potential [ __ ] murderer
true but I think they they might go to a
third party source because they might
the government itself might not have the
resources for that's a little outsource
it to someone it could don't take off
the monitor or let us know like that's
the scary for y'all y'all y'all paying
for this and then next time y'all sign
this bill later the subscription that's
a Chinese model hey you know pay like I
take off my okay I know you you think
that like it would be the other way
around yeah
look shadier have you guys known anybody
that has ever had an ankle monitor
yeah I'm Mindy's a neighbor yeah dish I
wanna know oh you know I'm just driving
around
well am Indian by yourself we don't know
whom Indians I'm watching right now who
is that who's Mindy she have enemies
princess TV name is princess Minnie if
you do not hook them up tonight 39 over
G so neighbor yeah well yeah nothing
really interesting it was just I was
driving to her house like girlier this
week and then the bunch of uh actually
want to say but but you guys are
standing middle the street and I was
like the honk at them and I looked down
his ankle oh he's got ankle breathing
look at this guy can I take that home
some Shia LeBeouf disturbia exactly if
you have an ankle monitor are you not
you're not allowed to leave the house
right all right how do you make money
then it's I thank you you're restricted
to a certain age I think it's my house
arrest I think it depends on the terms
because sometimes it's dependent on like
a a circle circumference or like a
radius of like a certain location or
it's like within your own house I saw
and then there's also uh was it
Tyreese and and in a fast and furious
and he was like his like location was
only in that like race race yeah how are
they supposed to make money huh yeah
it's not your I was right I was right
[ __ ] I supposed me why how they supposed
to make money to pay for that ankle
thingy yeah see then now they're just
set up for failure
are they assuming that he's getting like
um like a leave from his job like yo I
got a you know I feel like you get fired
yeah I feel your fire - well I got the
only way you would think like you know
someone has a maternity leave or they
set vacation day it's like yeah okay
he's levitation days for jail time that
is a good point
how is he supposed to make money when
you got an ankle bracelet
yeah it's like a double-edged sword at
that point it's like you know don't pay
well actually that's it I said I mean
get out of jail free card right there
what job can he get that he stuck it
telephony video editor hey you want a
job sir into the house you just steal it
Amazon dude Amazon I have an ankle
monitor as long as you have Amazon Prime
you still work from home oh yeah
what could make a partner videos from
home oh yeah that's a good thing because
Devon just told us our yeah Devon was
talking about that earlier how he did
it's like apparently like now it's a
huge thing to be able to make your own
it's like being a youtuber oh yeah it's
like that snapchat sex with sex workers
Oh
subscribe to my premium snapchat or some
actually had that kind of service on
soundtrack it's not it's not actual
serve official snapchat it's like it's
like you just add them to like the list
of people like somebody pays you $20 a
month and then you add them to the
snapchat it's like it's kind of like a
sexy twitch it's like a new polar bears
it's like a fans like hey Julia if you
could snapchat me you know your nudes
I'll pay you a hundred bucks a month
it's a smart subscription-based service
I'm like oh so you know it doesn't get
you know a little hole but you know I
think a lot of retweets
there's people like lobbying to like
consider that like sex where I think
it's the porn industry right that's like
saying like hey you guys can't be doing
this you're taking our money they're
just but I mean is it is it like sounds
about right
I mean I Vietnamese coffee shop girls do
that don't tell Mindy who wait this is
the same video that you can
check this out right in this one
bleep it just bleep what passes so many
loopholes this is a lot of loop you've
ever done what's it loophole hmm Jane
juris something just talk do you think
of some innocent loophole all right well
I'll do my really little loophole should
I talk about this I'll talk about it
recently my my friend Ellen Show I'm
like so excited yeah I'm sure they give
away free [ __ ] all the time right
they're giving away like mattresses and
of course they're not gonna like develop
mattresses at the actual show because no
one that's got like a yeah so they did
was that they gave out or not like these
uh like these coupon codes so then you
just go to the website just have any
coupon code then you go three mattress
but the thing was I was like Ellen and
there was like four digits for the
coupon code so we were just guessing the
Koopa the four digits so you could guess
like 9 9999 combinations right huh so he
just sat there in putting numbers we got
it done they called it letter they had
like a recall and because they like saw
that they had all these other missing
numbers yeah people probably claim yeah
my coupons being used but I'm use it so
they investigated and then he's got
recalled so all of them got recalled not
another so his coworker did it to he got
four mattresses [ __ ] greedy bastard
and then got one of them went out of the
floor
damn you just incriminating yourself to
you I know Loki Helen Alan come he's
right here keep your eyes dude I don't
know it wasn't it wasn't me they might
put you on ankle it pay for my ankle -
okay just don't pay for it I won't pay
for it I'm out
that's it the biggest loopholes I can
think of well not like illegal or
anything is like whenever bars over
trying to play Jake a party games and
we're doing practice games and they're
just sitting there trying to break the
game you know what I mean like whenever
we're playing a practice games Julia I
mean yeah but it's so second nature to
them like they don't want to follow the
rules they just want to figure out like
how they can get around yeah exactly
they're trying to get the
loopholes they're trying to go through
the loopholes and just make it work for
them yeah but what loophole did you do
that's what them doing a loophole of
although he was asking what loopholes
came to mind oh I see that that's the
first thing I did I don't know I don't
really have any loophole stories like I
feel like the closest thing I ever done
is whenever I'm looking for locations
for like our old JK film skits
um and it's like paid locations I
usually tell them that we're students
but not anymore are we all look old not
me no like I already felt weird saying
that it was like for a student film cuz
that's like the ghetto jail free card
stupid films yeah you get stopped by
like cops or something like that your
self suitabie no we're just getting
incriminating sort of mayonnaise
commercials I just can't do it guys me
nuts
dishonorable that's cuz you've got the
SAU goody two-shoes that's right
no the only crime I committed was I
stole a pack of gum when I was a kid
damn ankle monitor I'm telling my
parents right check out and you know how
they always have the little candy I was
like one daling you want I want gum
today and it actually just grabbed the
pack and like I knew what I was doing in
the sense that like cuz I was trying to
be really sneaky about it and I made
sure that I hid the gum and then I only
offered the gum to one of my siblings
until we were out of the grocery store
cuz that's what I felt like I was in the
clear but the time I didn't really know
that I was actually really stealing we
were just too young to like really
understand ooh but like and I think I
think what got me to that point too was
before they would used to have like all
those like gummy bears and gummi worms
out in the little plastic cases where
you just open the lid and you
so they're like what my dad would you be
like here have a sample and I was like
oh we can have sample and try one that's
something Costco but I don't know to the
sample wine my roommate and I used to go
and caught Costco dates back in the day
we haven't gone on one recently but we
used to go to Costco he got a Costco
card on Sundays that's the day that they
have like all the stations that will
open basically and you just go there for
lunch or something like that you don't
even got to pay you just get a free meal
yeah that's so mom dad I got you don't
worry hold on can I get three yeah all
right all right and that's a lot of work
when a hot dogs a dollar fifty that's a
dollar fifty you can put towards
something else eight towards a Call of
Duty mobile okay there you go there you
go
Adie mobile
[Music]
[Music]